hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are unboxing something super
exciting this is the Super NES classic
edition a few of my favorite games that
it has on it is number one Mario Kart I
feel like this game not only crafted my
childhood but also my adulthood so that
will probably be the first thing that I
play obviously Super Mario World super
punchouts
Legend of Zelda a link to the past
Yoshi's Island and so many more this is
the follow-up console to the NES classic
edition which is this little guy right
here I just cannot wait to play Mario
Kart oh we've got a nice little poster
here we've got our power brick it comes
with two controllers this is a surprise
one of the biggest complaints that I had
about the NES classic was it only had
one controller and by the time I went to
get a second controller they were all
sold out and impossible to find this is
so great
here's the controller I actually have
with an original hold on it I've got one
to compare about it this is vintage old
school this is brand-new
new school which is which you can't even
tell can you
you can now we've got the console itself
also a charging cable which is basically
just a microUSB and an HDMI cable oh my
goodness
toll now what's this look like in
comparison to this thing if you can tell
it's been discolored it has seen better
days to go from this to this here's our
NES classic into medicine to the SNES
classic
[Music]
well mount this Sun box let's go set it
up and play our first game okay it's
time to play here we are the interest
screen here's all of the games that we
can play Star Fox - a street fighter -
Castlevania oh my gosh well here it is
Mario Kart baby so this is kind of cool
because you can add a CRT filter you can
play it regular four by three or
pixel-perfect which i think is how we're
gonna play it look at this
you could pick different frames oh this
is cool okay let's see which one are we
gonna pick a place Mario Kart this is
beautiful 1992
should I play 50 cc I guess sure why not
I'm having flashbacks this is so insane
started from the bottom now we're here
oh like oh holy crap the controls this
is insane
this is nuts oh my gosh I'm trash I'm
trying to I'm trying to power slide but
clearly power sliding is not the way
that used to be
[Music]
power-sliding is very different is not
working I need to I need to get my
bearings if you guys better played Mario
Kart before you know the way that you
power slide well it's not how you don't
do it here there's no it's just one
single power side it's not that the
boost oh my god this is Sol I am
freaking out I'm doing such a bad job I
mean I might be first place but like
it's embarrassing what I'm driving I was
swerving all over this course so when
you power slide in some of the newer
games you can do like multiple bursts so
with those multiple bursts you're able
to get power-ups so I'm trying to do
that but that is not a thing here in
this Mario Kart let's see if I'm a
little bit better on this one
I cannot get the hang of it
[Music]
it's so weird I'm doing so bad first
place is not deserved of this
performance yeah definitely whoops now
I'm a little teeny-tiny mushroom
[Music]
yeah might as well knock him out he's
not my competition like these are mobile
games now if this is something you'd be
playing on your phone like back in my
day this was a revolutionary game oh
yeah we're getting the hang of it now
don't know I hit
[Music]
if I hate that stupid mushroom one more
time how many freakin mushrooms do you
have this is okay come on now you can't
realistically have that many that's
absurd
chef like 150 I mean I'm not doing well
clearly the skills that I'm displaying
here are quite embarrassing we let's go
let's go princess get off of my tail
yeah this turn is always such a struggle
[Music]
I'm focusing now I'm trying to play
trying to play my best best that I can
be here in Mario Kart I can't believe
what trash I was those first two rounds
like I really it took me a good while to
get the hang of these controls again and
then because the new controls now it
like everything is so different I can't
wait to play this with my friends like
it's gonna be so much fun
[Music]
a coin a lot I can barely focus on this
screen
the graphics are like seriously hurting
my eyes
all right give me my trophy okay I need
the race the best of my abilities here
we're gonna take these turns like
freaking champions that we are and we're
gonna get this trophy and bring home the
gold
[Music]
stupid powers live and it's not
happening Bowser yeah on my way get out
of my way get out of the way no
everything is not awesome like these
races feel so sure it's insane
[Music]
I am champion me my trophic you my
trophy you my trophy oh my god
pop some champagne
[Music]
flashbacks thank you guys so much for
watching hope you guys enjoyed this
unboxing and a little bit of gameplay
huge thank you to Nintendo for sending
me this early to check out I am so
excited because I feel like the Super
Nintendo was what kind of crafted my
adulthood love of gaming the NES is what
got me hooked but I feel like I was kind
of a little bit too young to really
appreciate it by the time the Super
Nintendo came out I was a little bit
older and I also remember switching
games with my friends
so was one of those things where we
would coordinate what game are you gonna
get I will get the other one so that
when you're done playing that one I can
then switch and train and then we can
all play all of the games anyway thanks
again for watching and I will see you
guys in my next video and that's it I
have got nothing else to say except a
slow-mo montage
[Music]
[Applause]